I think not really ever having a home
base has been incredibly good for me
because as an actor I don't live
anywhere I live in different hotels
wherever my characters live wherever the
movie is that's where I am and I think
when I was younger I used to really
struggle with the sense of identity and
then I sort of realized that that's
actually what makes me who I am it's the
fact that I do come from all of these
different places and I can have that
sort of understanding of different
cultures I think I'm just starting to
own kind of being a mismatched bunch of
stuff now I am Annie Taylor joy I'm 22
and I consider myself an artist I wish I
could say that I had a grand master plan
for what I was going to do with my
career it just so happens that I sort of
fell into her I think those characters
are more interesting and probably more
real in a way it was a great education
in film acting because it means that I'm
now there's very little that can shocker
or scare me on set I've got five
brothers and sisters and they will tell
you that I am never off I am literally
the duracell bunny I have so much energy
I don't think I ever found a kid that
could kind of keep up with me in
playtime so I just sort of played with
myself and created all these different
characters and would run off into the
woods and do that I think I've kind of
realized that being creative is just the
best therapy for me so if I'm not acting
I want to be writing poetry if I'm not
writing poetry I want to be making music
I want to be directing something or
writing something different and that's
been a really good thing to learn quite
early on because it just means that I
have an outlet to put all of my
intensity into learning how to be the
celebrity version of myself I think has
been quite because I am I'm a very I'm
an extrovert introvert but suddenly
Sabeel shiny and glamorous and all of
that kind of stuff that's not
necessarily where I'm where I feel
comfortable I feel a lot more
comfortable covered in blood and
screaming down like a an empty hallway
than I do in a glittering dress I'm
really excited because it's the first
year that I'm completely booked up
yes I actually know where I'm going to
be living which is nuts for me because
usually I'm just like this but I'm
really looking forward to taking more
time to kind of honor the artists inside
of myself
I'm learning the act of self-love it's a
tough journey but I'm learning it and I
think this year's the first year that
I'm going to actually do better